Seien Sie nicht matschig, immer noch nicht Trump, okay
, glauben Sie der gefälschten Bibel nicht, sie ist
voller Lügen, dummes Buch, das ist wirklich
passiert
war sowieso für Mexiko,
er packte sie an der Muschi und dann war
sie schwanger. Marias Ehemann Joseph, er
glaubte diese Bullshit-Geschichte, was für ein
Verlierer,
sehr arm, ich hasse ihn, sie hatten keine
Unterkunft,
also checkten sie im wunderschönen Trump
Hotel in Las Vegas ein  am besten einfach
genial und so an Heiligabend wurde
Jesuskind geboren das schönste Baby aller Zeiten zwei
Sekunden später behandelte Jesuskind Ich bin
geboren gut für mich und dann kam ein heiliger
König, sein Name ist Putin und er sagte, ich
liebe dieses Baby, ich werde ihn zum Präsidenten machen
und  So wurde ich Präsident Frohe
Weihnachten Frohes Neues Jahr, fick dich,
du,
du